use the cards below to create a list of
steps in order that will solve the
following equation three times X plus
six squared is equal to 75 and I
encourage you to pause this video now
and try to figure it out in your own
figure out which of these steps and in
what order you would do to solve for X
here so I'm assuming you've given it a
go so let's try to work through it
together and first let me just rewrite
the equation so we have 3 times the
quantity X plus 6 squared is equal to 75
so what I want to do is I want to
isolate the X plus 6 squared on the left
hand side or another way of thinking
about it I don't want this 3 here
anymore so how would I get rid of that 3
well I could divide the left-hand side
by 3 but if I do that to only one side
of the equation it won't be equal
anymore these two things in yellow were
equal to each other if I want the
equalities to hold anything that I do to
the left-hand side I have to do to the
right-hand side so let me divide that by
3 as well and so on the left-hand side I
am left with X plus 6 squared is equal
to 75 divided by 3 so 75 divided by 3 is
25 now if I told you that something
squared so actually let's let me just
pick out the first one I did I divided
both sides by 3 so that was my that was
my first step there let me write that in
a darker color so that was my first step
right over there
now let's think about what we're doing
we're saying that something squared
we're saying that something squared is
equal to 25 so this something could be
the positive or negative square root of
25 so let's take thee so we could write
this as X plus 6 is equal to the plus or
minus square root of 25 so I'm
essentially taking the positive and
negative square root of both sides so
let's see this looks like this step I
took the square root of both sides
that's step number 2 and so let me just
rewrite this this is the same thing as X
plus 6 is equal to plus or minus 5 and
I want to I want to just have an X on
the left-hand side I want to solve for X
that's the goal from the beginning so I
would like to get rid of this I'd like
to get rid of this six well the easiest
way to do that is to subtract six from
the left-hand side but just like before
I can't just do it from one side of an
equation then the Equality wouldn't be
true we're literally saying that X plus
six is equal to plus or minus five so X
plus six minus six is going to be equal
to plus or minus five minus six or
actually when we write it this way so
let me subtract six from both sides on
the left-hand side I'm left with an X
and on the right hand side I have and I
could write it this way negative six let
me do it in that green color I have
negative six plus or minus plus or minus
five so what are the possible values of
X or actually I keep forgetting I we
don't have to actually give the value
for X we just have to say what steps we
did so then let's see after we took the
square root of both sides we then
subtracted 6 from both sides so that was
step three right over there then they
got that got us to essentially the two
possible X's that would satisfy this
equation right over here and just for
fun let's actually solve it all the way
so if we solve it all the way we get two
so X is equal to negative six plus five
is negative one or X is equal to
negative six minus five is negative 11
and you could verify but that both of
these work if you put either of em in
here if you put negative one here you
get negative one plus six squared is 5
squared if you put negative 11 here it's
negative 11 plus 6 is negative 5 squared
obviously either plus or minus five
squared is going to be 25 25 times 3 is
75 so these are our three steps we
divided both sides by 3 subtract it then
we took the square root of both sides
then we subtracted 6 from both sides and
then we were essentially done so let's
input those steps so the first thing we
do it would divide both sides by 3
that's the first thing we did then we
took the square root of both sides and
then we subtracted 6 from both sides we
got it right